all right it is time for hatred mail if
you're a new viewer or listener to the
show and you're not familiar with hatred
mail here's what it is we're so all
right it's wrong patriot mail written by
Patriots who hate david pakman because
america and because freedom i
experienced some pretty serious
disturbance as a result of this week's
hey treat male let's take a listen to it
together president Trump david pakman is
a [ __ ] [ __ ] boy [ __ ] why you worried
what Trump says about black people that
white [ __ ] loves blacks and Latinos
you should be deported to a rock you [ __ ]
David fudge packer man is fake news he
won't even cover beats and gates I
reserve the right to call someone I
don't like a [ __ ] and not get arrested
for it why would you deport me to Iraq
usually it's Argentina where I was born
or Israel are although I've never lived
nor had Israeli citizenship I don't know
how you would justify deporting me
they're fake news now is code for a
point of view that you don't like that's
the new thing that's how fake news is
being used and I won't cover pizza gate
Ivy this is just insane and who gets
arrested for using slurs about gay
people unless you're also combining that
with some kind of physical intimidation
in some way that would be that would be
a crime otherwise people don't get
arrested for using LGBT slurs I got to
be honest I think my troll alarm is
going off there's just way too many red
flags and a lot of these caught a lot of
these sentences just kind of contradict
themselves yeah well that's one of the
two primary sort of characteristics of
patriot mail are the message is
completely internally or inherently
contradictory and number two it's
written in a way that makes absolutely
no sense so in that way it's like every
other hatred mail that we received
remember you can turn hey treat male
into something positive use coupon code
hey tree at forty Patriot 42 get a huge
discount off of membership at david
pakman.com slash membership